良いか？
ここに物差しがある
これをこうして
こうして
こうするのじゃ！
こうするとな
（飛んでいく効果音）
（物差しを手に叩く音）
あっ痛くね？思ったより痛い
はい。というわけで今ご覧いただきましたように
物差しにはものすごい可能性がある
昔やっていたじゃないですか
こうね、端っこを押さえて
勢いをつけると！
このねービヨヨーンとなるんすよ
これでよく後輩をぶん殴ってはいないです(笑)
プラスチックでよく曲がるんで
これを使うと
物をここに置くと凄い勢いでジャンプするんですよ
パゥーンってね★
そこで天才はじめちゃんはひらめいてしまった
そう,それで小さいものを置いて飛ぶことはわかったので
飛ぶことはわかったので
これをたくさん準備すると
ひょっとして俺も飛べるんじゃないか
物差しでジャンプ台を作れるんじゃないかって
僕は思ってしまったんだ
だから今日は
ビャーー
すごいついに文房具で
空を飛ぶやつが出る時代になったよ
すごいなぁー
これは10個入りかな　おーー
はい　というわけで今回はこちらに物差しを
50本準備しました
この物差しのグニャ曲がり感を使って
一本だと間違いなく折れるのはわかってるんで
この50本をつなぎ合わせて強度を強くして
僕が乗っても折れない巨大物差しを作って
それで僕がちょっと今日ね　こう
ジャンプしてみようと思います
ちゃんと作れば絶対飛べると思ってるんで
お前たち俺に惚れるんじゃねーぞ
今日俺は文房具で空を飛ぶ
あんまりかっこよくないな　ではいこう！！
30センチ物差しを
50本準備しました
わっ　すごいなぁー
これすごいよ
はじめくんすごい
ものさし50本も持ってるのねぇ♡
すごい！はじめくんなんでもはかれるじゃん！うわぁーー！
（物差しを開ける音）
（物差しを開けるかけ声）
うお！戻ってきた　すごい
いった！（痛い）
うわぁ！ITAP
ITAPってなんだよ（笑）
（物差しを開けるかけ声）
よっしゃー　できました
50　オッケーです
ちゃんと50本あります
この50本の物差しをガムテープでくっつけて
巨大な物差しを作ります
縦に伸ばしすぎても、たぶん折れちゃうんで
そんなにたぶん長さは、いらないんすよ
いかに、分厚くできるかがポイントな気がします
これは、ちょ、まじやばい　まじやべぇ
これ完全にやばい
うわ　完璧なフレームだ
よしよしよしよし
はい　完成です！！
こちらでございます
これやばくないすか？　このしなり感
はい　というわけで、無事完成しました
完璧です
もう今回は成功する気しかしないので
いや、よく作ったよ
かなりね　強く作ってあります
ガムテープも強めにして
ここら辺とかも30重になってますね　完璧でございやす
まじで飛べる気がするんで
早速飛んでみましょう
こちらしっかり止めていきましょう
まじ、しっかり止めるの大事
まじで、ここでしっかり止めないと死にますから
これならたぶん、僕が乗っても大丈夫でしょう
バッチリ止まってます
え　これ待って　まじかー　まじかー
いや　大丈夫だとは思ってるけどさ
そしたら　もう　いきます　いきますよ
キメますよ
乗ればいいんだ　乗ん　乗　あ...（キッチンペーパー落ちる）
キメればいいんだよ
乗ってジャンプすれば勝ち
いきます
（ガラスの音）
ここが長すぎた
もっと奥深くにすれば、たぶん大丈夫
これぐらいだ
そう　これぐらいならいけます
これぐらいなら絶対大丈夫
さっきは、ちょっとね　深すぎたんだよ
だから　こう...ジャンプすらできない
今度ならしっかり飛べます
よしよしよし...
（ガラスの音）
乗れないのー？
痛ーー！！！